Katrina:  这简笔画真做的越来越好看了
Katrina: These simple drawings are getting prettier and prettier.
Shure: 他他妈又给我打的电话
Shure: He called me again, damn it.
Katrina:  好恶心的舌头
Katrina: That tongue is so disgusting.
Katrina:  画的跟爷爷一样
Katrina: Drawn just like Grandpa.
Nicous: 我靠我发现没有你我卖不了一点
Nicous: Wow, I realized that without you, I can't sell a thing.
Nicous: 基本根本找不到
Nicous: Basically can't find anything.
Katrina: 来吧我正好想买东西
Katrina: Come on, I actually want to buy something.
Katrina: 又不用花自己的钱
Katrina: And I don't have to spend my own money.
Shure: 买什么什么
Shure: What are you buying?
Katrina: 化妆品
Katrina: Makeup.
Shure: 什么化妆品
Shure: What makeup?
Katrina: 你会吗你给你女朋友挑过吗
Katrina: Do you even know? Have you ever picked any for your girlfriend?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Katrina: 你这
Katrina: You...
Nicous: 他没有女朋友他只有好兄弟
Nicous: He doesn't have a girlfriend, he only has good buddies.
Katrina: 他生气喽
Katrina: He's mad now.
Nicous: 他不会生气的
Nicous: He won't get mad.
Nicous: 这是他的骄傲
Nicous: It's his pride.
Katrina: soulmate人家是soulmate
Katrina: They're soulmates, you know, soulmates.
Shure: 每天抱着兄弟你好香
Shure: Hugging his buddy every day saying "You smell so good."
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿啊
Shure: Hehehe, yeah.
Shure: 好兄弟就应该躺在一张床上
Shure: Good buddies should sleep in the same bed.
Katrina: 可以听吗
Katrina: Can I listen?
Shure: 可以听
Shure: You can listen.
Shure: 你不止可以听你可以加入
Shure: Not only can you listen, you can join.
Nicous: 你真喝多了
Nicous: You've really had too much to drink.
Katrina: 可是被录下来了呀
Katrina: But it's being recorded!
Nicous: 录下来发给我我直接给他对象
Nicous: Record it and send it to me, I'll send it straight to his partner.
Shure: 什么乐死你了啊
Shure: What's so funny about that?
Katrina: 怎么这样
Katrina: How could you do that?
Shure: 就是不说好
Shure: Just don't talk about it.
Shure: 我在这七天里
Shure: In these seven days.
Shure: 闭口不谈吗
Shure: Not a word, okay?
Nicous: 不谈
Nicous: Not a word.